[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in
let's bring in mike florio pro football
talk live co-host
uh i don't know what you make of what we
just said there mike but we did fill up
about uh four minutes
yeah no i it allowed me to catch up on
some text messages
so i appreciate that was mclovin being
mean to drew brees
he wasn't being mean to do a breeze look
there are
categories like this where reasonable
minds will differ the thing that
impresses me the most about drew brees
number one
inch for inch pound for pound arm
strength for arm strength i think he got
more out of his god-given abilities than
any other quarterback in the history of
the nfl and the
statistical things that amaze me the
most dan number one
breaking the johnny unitas record of
consecutive games with a touchdown pass
47 it stood for so long unbelievable how
long it stood brees broke that and
extended it to 54. and also
there had been one 5 000 yard season
before drew brees in 2011. that was dan
marino
well actually breeze got to 5 000 before
2011 he broke the record in 11.
dan marino had 50 84 in 1984.
brees has five 5
000 yard seasons no one else has more
than
one now that's going to change with 17
games and just the way the game is
moving
but just from the standpoint of
statistical accomplishment
and and changing the narrative forever
when it comes to
short quarterbacks he deserves a spot
in that top ten whether it's five
whether it's eight whether it's ten
again reasonable minds can differ but
he's one of the all-time greats
and the uh heir apparent in new orleans
is going to be
i think it's taysom hill sean payton has
set on record on multiple occasions
he wants jameis winston to re-sign
and compete the question is what dollar
value can you put on a jameis winston
contract especially when
you're scrambling to get under the
salary cap as it is
restructuring every contract possible
cutting guys that you would like to keep
on the team surely they would have liked
to have kept
emmanuel sanders some guys are just
going to have to move on from
but hill's making about 12 million this
year ignore the
stuff yesterday about the four-year 140
million dollar contract that's all made
up that's all phony that's that's but
explain that though mike because we all
looked at it went wait what are they
doing in new orleans well
we've seen this more and more recently
and i think the reduced salary cap this
year dan has a lot to do with it
teams are adding voidable years on to
contracts so they can
spread cap dollars a signing bonus gets
spread over multiple years
so when you have a guy like taysom who's
got one year left on his contract
there's nowhere to spread any of the
money so you have to do a new contract
with voidable years avoidable means fake
phony they're going to go away the
contract disappears
so you add four years and i i don't
think it was an accident
that the value was 35 million per year
140 million that's the russell wilson
contract i think that was kind of a
an impish little wink nod by the saints
and by taysom hill that they're not
going to be getting russell wilson or
even trying to
but that gets presented as four years
140 million dollars
and it's fake it's phony it's not real
he's not getting that
but there's people out there who see it
and they think oh they're paying him 35
million a year when they're not it was
just a device for creating 7.75 million
in cap space that they may end up using
to keep jameis winston
will be the top competition for taysom
hell at quarterback you
you think taysom hill is going to be the
starting quarterback in new orleans
i think he's got the inside track on the
job he passed the test last year
when drew brees was injured the question
is can he stay healthy
and counting outperform jameis winston
in a head-to-head competition winston's
been there for a year
first winston has to agree to whatever
they're offering for him to stay
we'll find out after noon eastern on
monday whether or not somebody else
swoops in and tries to sign him
but dan you look at it from winston's
perspective i don't see another
team that's going to offer him a clear
shot to a starting job
his best play maybe to take whatever he
can get
in new orleans try to secure the job
this year
win the competition this year and then
set himself up for a contract next year
any news on the russell wilson front
with the bears offering whatever they're
supposedly offering even something that
you're not allowed to offer which is
you know first round picks the next five
years which you can only do
four years but we were told it was five
years it like
seattle hasn't engaged like this is
this is a game of tennis but they
haven't returned serve here mike
well i i've i've heard that it's
crickets right now
as far as any talk about a possible
trade that doesn't mean it can't happen
but if the bears are going to do it
they're getting closer and closer to the
point where they have to figure out what
they're going to do
because their plan b plan c plan d plan
e plan f
is going to potentially dry up so you
know at some point
you're going to see the bears make a
move that's going to slam the door just
like the cowboys last
week with prescott slams the door i
think the saints doing this
restructuring with taysom hill
slams the door there here's the real
question
that i have because i'm not sure the
bears can put together enough of a
package that would get the seahawks
interest we know that mark rogers
russell wilson's agent has identified
four teams raiders bears cowboys saints
here's the question are there other
teams
that he's holding back that russell
wilson would
accept a trade to if the alternative is
staying in seattle
could the panthers make the list could
the jets
who have that second overall pick and
four total
first round picks over the next two
years two of them previously belonged to
the seahawks before the jamal adams
trade
could the jets be a place could the
dolphins be a place if it doesn't work
out
with deshaun watts and so it makes me
wonder are there other teams
were the four just a starting point
because i think it's going to take
someone
who can really give the seahawks an
obvious path
to a franchise quarterback to get this
thing done this year otherwise
deal with the dysfunction for a year and
do a trade next year
assuming that there is dysfunction i
think the raiders make the most sense
out of all this i can get a quarterback
in return because if i'm pete carroll
i don't want gino's like who's my
quarterback here you know
andy dalton or what i mean fill in the
blank throw out
somebody there i got to get a franchise
quarterback of sorts
and i got to get draft picks here and
that to me makes more sense than the
bears do
well and then the question becomes would
john gruden really want
to shift from derek carr to russell
wilson given what he's gonna have to
give up to get russell wilson
you know john gruden always wants a
different quarterback than the one he
has but then the opportunity comes to
get one and now i kind of like the guy
that i have
given that i'd have to give up a bunch
of stuff to go get russell wilson you
know derek carr's got three years in
this system now
he's getting to the point where he's
comfortable doing
what gruden wants gruden has gotten him
to that
level how long would it take to get
russell wilson
to where you need him to be and and the
other side of it too dan
when you trade for one of these
quarterbacks who isn't real happy where
he currently is you're inheriting
those problems what if you can't protect
him the way that he'd like to be
protected
what happens the next time he's up for a
contract he's going to want to get to 45
million a year
every time he does a new contract he
gets at or close to the top of the
market
so it's not just getting him it's
keeping him that's an issue too
and i i i i just think that
even though it's got the potential to be
an issue that hovers over the seahawks
all year long
and any adversity any issues any losses
any multiple
turnover performances that question's
going to come up
for pete carroll for russell wilson for
other players it's the ultimate
distraction
but i i it looks like they're just going
to try to deal with it for a year
unless they get blown away by someone
and russell says okay i'll take a trade
to that team do you think russell wilson
if he goes to a new team
is going to stand pat with his current
contract given what
everybody else is making no no no that's
what nobody is talking about
yes you're gonna have to give up all
that stuff to get him
and then as soon as he walks through the
door
ideally you want to get the deal done
i'm not a big fan of these contracts
we've seen the past couple of years
whether it's laramie tunsil
jaylen ramsey jamal adams you give up
multiple first round picks for a guy who
has a contract you're eventually gonna
have to deal with if you don't deal with
it all the way through the door
he has all the leverage as you go
forward because what are you going to do
not pay him when you've given up
multiple first-round draft picks to get
the guy
so we saw the texans overpay tunsil we
saw the rams arguably over pay ramsey
we're going to see the seahawks
potentially over pay adams
i'd want to get a new deal done with
russell wilson on the way in because the
thing is
over the next year or two it's only
going to get more expensive aaron jones
signing
a team friendly contract would you say
well the devil's always in the details
and the details remain concealed
especially on the first day that the
news comes out
look the packers could have kept him for
the next two years under the franchise
tag
at a total payout of 19 million dollars
my understanding haven't seen the
numbers yet but my understanding is this
four-year 48 million dollar deal
is two years 19 million and then it's a
packers option for year three and year
four like so many of these deals are
it's guaranteed for two years
three at the most and then it's a team
option every year after that but if they
could have kept him for 19 million
under the tag for last year and this
year i don't know why they'd pay him
more than 19 million
to sign him to a long-term deal
especially when they got aj dillon
second-round pick last year what you
know packers fans get salty when i point
this
out and i don't know whether it's
because only packers fans are allowed to
say this
but what the hell were they doing with
their draft picks last year could you
imagine if they had actually invested
their first round pick and a receiver or
someone who would have
you know played last year would that
have been the difference
in the game against the buccaneers would
they have gotten to the super bowl and
potentially won it
and how can you not be questioning what
they were thinking about
that burning desire to win now they have
a team that's ready to win now dan
well they also they draft a quarterback
then they drive to running back you know
right
and and you're right because if i'm
green bay bringing back aaron jones is
wonderful
i don't have a playmaker defensively
that you know
can change a game and my offensive line
i still have to make sure i shore that
up if
you know tampa is going to make another
run at this what do you expect to happen
this week any anything big in free
agency
well people are always going to get paid
at the top and it may not be as many
guys but the
stars are going to get paid this salary
camp cap reduction is going to hurt
the middle level guys and the one
position that fascinates me because we
know how important pass rush is
there are so many pass rushers available
in free agency i think that's why the
buccaneers
didn't franchise tag shaq barrett and i
have a feeling they're going to let him
walk away because two years ago dan they
got him for one year
four million dollars and he had 19 and a
half sacks there are so many names
out there of guys that you could plug
into that defense
and maybe they just get another shaq
barrett from 2019 instead of breaking
the bank to keep him
let someone else pay him let him get his
reward you could get two or three guys
or more to address other needs on your
team
than what it would be in comparison to
pay shaq barrett so i think he gets paid
by somebody who just wants to be able to
hold up a new jersey and say we took
tampa bay's best defensive player
meanwhile tampa bay is going to find
somebody who dollar for dollar has more
production
shaq barrett's in our bracket challenge
as you are as well
do you know anything about college
basketball nothing okay nothing you
probably do well
i usually know very little this year
it's less than ever before
i'm just gonna i don't know what i'm
gonna do just random flip a coin
something i'm i'm gonna but but uh i
can't do any worse than if i actually
knew anything i've tried it that way
it doesn't work thank you mike great to
talk to you see you dan that's mike
floria